there's good and bad without there's
knowledge which I completely barter and
a universe that's tied by bonds of
democracy rather than warned and
splintered savagery hey youtubers it's
Charlie and I just wanted to say thank
you for helping me reach twenty thousand
subscribers so fast as a way to say
thank you I just like to react to some
of this Benedict Cumberbatch Star Wars
casting news in a funny way
so please enjoy so to speak seriously
about Star Wars 7 for a minute we
actually don't know who is going to be
in the movie that is the main cast we
know some of the returning cast members
from the original trilogy will be there
like Mark Hamill Carrie Fisher Harrison
Ford we also know there's going to be
spin-offs for Yoda and Boba Fett as well
as Han Solo but we don't know who these
new main cast members are going to be
over the holiday weekend there was a
rumor posted that Benedict Cumberbatch
was actually joining the cast a lot of
this was based on his scheduling
conflicts with crimson peak that's
Guillermo del Toro's movie that he was
supposed to do as well as comments he
made in earlier interviews about really
really wanting to be in a Star Wars
movie so this is from earlier in the
year and this is what he said I thought
yeah I grew up with them and I just
looked recently at when they were
released and now I'm like no I didn't
grow up with them I was born with them
they were a huge part of my background
and my upbringing I was much more
connected to Star Wars as a kid in a way
that a lot of kids are because it's
immediate storytelling very simple a
beautifully outrageously simple
narrative in a way and wonderful
three-act melodrama
opera and I love them I really really
love those films and I always wanted to
be Han Solo so that's from his own mouth
he really wants to be Han Solo obviously
he's not going to be Han Solo in this
new movie because Han Solo is han Solo
Harrison Ford is returning there were
earlier rumors that there would be a han
Solo type character that they would be
introducing in this new trilogy that is
a character to kind of take the place
that Han Solo had in that original film
but not the actual character of Han Solo
but what does that mean it's still
totally possible that Benedict
Cumberbatch could be in these new Star
Wars films the rumors are stating that
he's going to be a Sith Lord and while
that would kind of fit with this con
character from Star Trek into darkness I
don't really think that JJ Abrams would
do something so obvious is taking him
from Star Trek into darkness as a
villain and putting him in Star Wars as
the villain obviously Benedict
Cumberbatch is one of the best actors
out there so he's really complex but
honestly if he's going to be in this new
movie and he's going to be a force user
of some kind I don't think he's going to
be a
but let me know what you think just to
have some fun and to say thank you for
all your support and helping me get to
20,000 subscribers so fast let's list
some of the best fake names that
Benedict Cumberbatch might have in this
new Star Wars film and they go
butterscotch crumbly snacks bendy dick
Charizard bellissimo thunder crotch
Bluff or doodle garden hose vandal
smooch cuddle bug brandybuck wombats -
bumblebee cranky pants that's one of my
favorites BBQ cuddle Bunch bagel sugar
crumpet muffin blabber scoop crumble
chat uncle spurt crumply bum benadryl
itchy snacks that's that's just a good
one
blunderbuss Captain Crunch and Scooby
Doo bumble cakes so like I said earlier
this week I'll be posting my Jamie
Lannister
Game of Thrones season 4 preview
tomorrow if you have any other
characters that you'd like to hear about
on Game of Thrones I've got a new video
series coming I talk about it all those
are the videos be sure to subscribe to
get them all be sure to add your
favorite Benedict Cumberbatch fake Star
Wars name in the comments below you can
click here to get all my other Star Wars
Episode 7 videos and you can click here
to get my first Game of Thrones season 4
character preview that's for Tyrion
thank you so much watching high fives
here's to the next 20,000
you